ok let's go for the last game of today  play you for and hope for some line that  I at least know a bit about ok let's  let's let's go right here with the Kings  gambit  the  but at least I'm not a lot of material  down we just take and get some good  development going 95 to okay can you  really play g5 now talk about that  doesn't want to  what about 95 now what then bishop d6  then take on a phone maybe  whoa  didn't see this one coming  hmm  ok no idea looks like why should be able  to refute it but I don't see it  okay i need to move once in a while  check  check  was wrecking them on King Queen f7 now  yeah but this is a mate black resigns  yeah okay nice quick quick finish for  the day okay thanks for watching